Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
uh, January 25th, 2060.
What's going on our,
how are you? Ah, you know how
I'm doing? I'm not doing good.
Ah, everybody in Denver settling in
with a big fucking smile on your face,
aren't ya? Ha.
You fucking pot smoking
cuts with the God damn hemp.
Ponchos um, congratulations
to the Broncos.
They deserve to right out of the
gate. You know, we took the ball,
they stopped us. And I remember when they
scored in the first drive, I was like,
that was disturbingly easy. Um,
and uh, you know, they
just, we have, they just
von Fucking Miller. I mean, if the,
if he was in the backfield
any quicker during the game,
he'd be taking the fucking
snap. I mean, it was brutal.
We just didn't have any answers
on the outlet, the book. And, uh,
that's what did it,
not the fucking field goal and not
us going forward and forth down.
I can only imagine what they're seeing
on, I'm doing this Sunday night.
I can imagine the sports talk radio that
they're second guessing bill Belichick.
Yeah. Second guessing. Yes. Second guess
them. It's just bill Belicheck. Oh,
what are you? Yeah,
you're the other fucking,
you've never coached on any fucking,
you can level [inaudible] kick
the field goal there. One,
there would have been a [inaudible] floor
to take four kitchens or toward show
[inaudible] fuck.
I love how people think like, like
something earlier in the game.
If they just did this, that, that, that
doesn't change everything after that.
I mean, how many fucking back to the
futures do they have to make that you see,
if you change one thing, that
it changes everything else.
So if the Patriots did kick the fucking
thing and we got to within five and when
we got the ball back,
the fact that a touchdown would put us
ahead rather than us being down by eight,
they would have had a completely
different fucking defense. Okay.
Before they fucking do all of that
second guessing shit. You know,
fucking Versie was going through that
thought that I said I was saying.
I was saying when they did, it was dumb.
Oh did you non coach Versie to
listen to you as opposed to to,
to fucking Belicheck. Um,
when they did it, I was like,
I love the, I love the call going forward.
We weren't able to move the fucking ball
at all on offense the entire fucking
game. We will,
the only reason why we had a touchdown
was because they had that fucking
lateral. And even then, then we
missed a fucking extra point. It just,
it wasn't our day. Even
when we had got a gift,
we fucked it up and then we gave it right
back with a pick and then they scored.
But um, yeah, we weren't able
to move the fucking ball.
Every time Brady went back, there
was somebody in his face, you know,
chomping at the fucking his,
his legs as he was trying to throw the
fucking thing. You're that close. I, I,
I agreed with going
forward. It didn't work out,
but you know how life is sometimes.
So, um, but it was a great season and,
um, for what they accomplished with all
the injuries and all that type of shit,
it was amazing. And, uh, I
got to tell you, I am, um,
I'm definitely rooting
for, uh, Peyton manning.
I'd like to see him go out like John
Elway would be pretty cool for another guy
in the Broncos does that. But uh, then
you also, you've got to love Cam Newton.
You know, Jesus Christ, you only
guy not like about Cam Newton.
It's one more person tells me there's
nobody having more fun than him.
Nobody ever called for to care to a,
it's like a kid on
Christmas a, he's like a,
he's like a kid with a second birthday.
It's like, I get it. He's having fun.
He's also totally fucking hamming it up
and making sure his next sneaker deal
would be, it will be even 10 times.
What the fuck he has right now.
Let's not just, let's start,
be totally naive here.
It just act like everything he's doing
is just because he loves playing the
game. He wasn't this
fucking animated what?
He was at a a fucking Auburn.
I used to watch those games
rote against [inaudible].
I used to wear it against him
so I would watch and I was, oh,
he wasn't doing all that
shit. But then again,
he couldn't get paid or at least legally
he couldn't get paid back then. So,
you know, what was the point? A
dance it every time you fuck it.
I love when that one
guy fucking, uh, they,
they through the screen pass and he ran
all the way to the other side of the
field. By the time he gets there,
Cam Newton runs in with them and
kind of fucking jumps in on that guy.
Superbowl super was his
touchdown salivate celebration.
And then the camera man is just following
Cam Newton for the rest of the time.
And um,
in my, uh, in my business, that's a,
okay,
that's called a [inaudible] steel on a
scene. It's called, uh, uh, Jesus Christ.
I don't do enough acting to even know
stealing the xen is when you're better
than the other person. Upstaging
somebody. He was upstaging him. So, um,
I, I just don't need anybody else telling
me how much fun Cam Newton's having.
I get it. He's having a good time,
but he's also completely hamming
it up because when he does,
he makes a zillion dollars. However, as
crushing as the Patriot's loss was like,
I literally had to,
I had to go for a walk after they
lost. Um, and I gotta tell you,
I felt like we were
going to lose that game.
Okay.
You know, sometime in the second quarter,
I was just like, this, I can feel it.
This just isn't our day. It
just wasn't Brady never, I mean,
they will all over and he
never got comfortable and, uh,
he wasn't screaming and yelling and
getting people going. I thought,
but our fucking defense played great. Um,
but I g I don't know,
sometimes you can just feel,
it's just not your fucking day. So
I literally had to go for a walk,
went to the bank, I mailed
something, I got the car washed.
It was like nobody, there was like a
ghost town. It was just like, you know,
some fucking nerds or whatever
who don't give a shit about,
and some poor bastards who
had to work. And, um, yeah,
I went to the car wash and then I
went to this, uh, uh, I don't know,
Mediterranean, Middle East and one of
the fuck it has got one of those reps,
the Shwarma wraps, whatever
the fuck you call it.
And it actually worked out perfectly. I
walked a few blocks over. I got the rap,
I ate it, I watched some of
the Carolina Arizona game.
And then when I came back,
right as I came back,
the guy was finishing my car
and he put his hand up like go,
whose car resist is fucking
perfect, perfect timing. Um,
that was about the only a good thing
that happened during those three hours of
watching the fucking
game. But, um, anyways,
I got to tell you is as bad as, um,
as bad as the, the feeling I
had when the Patriots lost. Um,
the one thing that cheered
me up was watching that
Carolina fans fall out of the
fucking stance. That was one
of the funniest fucking things.
I've seen it a long
time. He just completely,
he missed timed when the player
was coming down. I think he,
I think he just ran down and he just,
Mitch misjudge where the rail was and
he just slammed into it and just went
right up and over, straight
up and over. I mean if you,
if you put a coat rack on wheels,
it would have landed lighter than
this guy did. There was just no,
nothing athletic about it.
It was just all fucking,
was it a nourishes that the proper
physics, Jeremy just read that.
I just wish I could have heard his
thoughts when he was at the tipping point
when his legs were right up.
But pointing at the 12 and his head was
at six o'clock right as it started to
come around till about 1145 you know,
he was lying to himself hanging onto the
rail. Like, I got this, I got this. Ah,
fuck.
Oh it is stupid dad jeans just shooting
up in the air right from the gap.
It just fucking lands on the
ground. I liked when he got up to,
and then he tried to like climb back up
in the stands and that dude was it like
I had nobody. I, what, what,
why don't you just walk around?
We don't need your fallen down again. Um,
okay.
I'll tell you what the
funny thing is is, you know,
there's going to be some lawyer scaring
the fuck out of the owner of that team.
Then emotionless maniac that they kept
cutting to when he would just be sitting
there like he was listening to the
verdict of his own murder trial. Um,
the fuck is what that guy is. He
just focused on the super bowl.
Everybody in his luxury box is going nuts.
He's got his fucking fired up a wife.
That's when you know you got money when
your wife has a fur coat and hasn't been
spray painted. You know,
that's when you know that [inaudible] you
guys are living a level of wealth that
you don't even run into
commoners to you. You know,
there's always some content's got to come
along and fucking spray paint somebody
for a coat, which I've never understood.
It's like the animal died and now
he's going to throw out a tidy,
at least it was a jacket. You know
what I mean? Like, if somebody came on,
killed me and made a jacket out of me,
I wouldn't want you to spray paint it,
you know, and then they're
just going to throw it out.
Then I'm just like a fucking jacket,
you know, on a landfill, right.
Floating in the ocean. Let
the bitch walk around with it.
Um, anyways, Jesus fucking
Christ. I'll tell you right now,
nobody's having more fun in
the national football league.
Oh God. I was watching the
game with a buddy of mine.
We were just throwing out the cliches
out there. He gets, he gets here.
He's the first one here. When
he's the last one to leave.
I'll tell you right now, you
can be 22 guys like that.
I could coach his date goes to Bob.
I'll tell you right now, you have
to know where you are on the field.
Why would you run a five yard route when
you need six yards for a first down?
I mean, that just doesn't make any sense.
Okay,
I'll tell you out there they
are. [inaudible] they're
just having fun out there.
They're just having fun. That's what
this game's all about. They're out there,
they're loose. He's just
out there slinging it. Um,
anyways, and just like that. My
fucking football season is over.
So who do you like in the Super Bowl?
I'll tell you what I don't like.
Have you seen that fucking
advertisement for Super Bowl 50,
the 50s and gold and for whatever reason,
this, this woman's standing, yeah.
Looking like the hot chick that walks in
in some gumshoe movie from the fucking
1940s.
She stayed in there in a raincoat and
high heels with like a golden umbrella
telling you it's, it's over.
It's fucking over. The bills hired a, uh,
I didn't know what they are. They
had a woman for some job over,
it's fucking over. It's done. It's done.
Those three hours where you
could get away as a married guy,
you could just get away for three
hours. It's just, it's over. It's, I, I,
it's gonna sound like
the Westminster dog show
in about seven years. You
know, we had a great run,
we had a great run, and now it's over,
you know, but it's our own damn
faults. It's our own damn fault.
You know what it was?
We just couldn't hide the joy we were
having watching football without him.
We couldn't hide the joy in, there's
nothing that annoys a fucking woman,
like a bunch of guys going and
having a good time without them.
So they're in that dressing in pink for
a fucking month. It's, it's fucking,
it's fucking over.
Uh,
I wish I just knew. I just knew,
I wish I knew that it was going to come
to this. I would have tried to enjoy,
you know,
my first 37 38 years of football
where they just flew by.
I would've tried to enjoy him a
little bit more and now it's over.
We should make a trade, which is what
we should do. We should just trade them.
The WNV just go like, well,
what if we just give you
a league that we started?
It'd be almost like a divorce where you
just get it even though you didn't do
anything.
Or maybe like emotionally supported the
guy or some shit or whatever the fuck he
say at the court. Right. You
just give them the w NBA.
You can be the commissioners, all the
owners, the commentators, the rafts.
You can be everybody in the stands.
We'll give you your section
of Buffalo wild wings yet now
just, just don't take NFL football from
us. Can you? Can you just not just,
can you give us, can you just leave
us with that? Can we just have that?
Oh God. Maybe I'm just
too old to understand it.
Coach, can you tell us what
happened there in the first half?
No. Know we weren't good to Donna.
No, we got to get off there.
Know fuck the baby.
I just don't know if I'm ready for that.
You know? I don't know.
I just, you know, I don't, I don't know
where, where do you go now? I guess.
I guess the only place left is you become
one of those weird old guys that plays
chess on the park.
Your is about chess.
It's boring and quiet enough that they
don't notice that you're over there
without them enjoying yourself. You know?
That's the genius. You ever see a guy
who's been married for like 50 years?
Like the genius of him, I swear to God,
the genius of them is they fucking,
they know how to have a good time
without their wife noticed it.
So it doesn't peak your interest.
Right. She's fucking over in the corner.
She don't give a shit. Right.
But young guys were idiots.
We come home with a big grin on her face
talking about how awesome it was, blah,
blah.
And all they hear is this motherfucker
had the nerve to go out for three hours
and not miss me and not
think about me. Well,
we'll see about that, won't we? Um,
it's fucking over. Ah, it's over.
Just like the Patriots season. So
who do you guys like in the, um,
who do you guys like in the, uh,
okay.
I'm trying to think of an
activity that women do.
Fucking group that they have that
I would like to infiltrate. And I,
for the life of me, I can't think of
it. You know, what are they got though?
The F the four h club girl scouting.
Um,
any of those feminist groups.
That'd be a funny thing to join.
Join one of those fucking groups
and act like you're a feminist.
You just go down there and you say like
the most ignorant but like yet it's
still pro women shit come down
there with a fucking bud tall.
Yeah. I just wanted to say, you know,
I came down here to support you broads.
You know, I think it's a, I think it's
fucked up the way that guy treats you.
You know,
just cause you run around with a skirt
and it takes you long to get ready.
Doesn't mean you can't run the company.
Right. Am I right ladies? Go buy a bill.
Um, we really appreciate
you coming down here.
We think what you're saying is positive,
which is just some buzzwords here
that we, uh, put into a spreadsheet,
a little pamphlet thing that we'd like
you to look at. Maybe could not say them.
The next meeting. Maybe take
a couple of weeks off. Oh Duh.
I'm showing up every week.
Okay.
Wait for them to kick me out.
Then I sue them for being sexist.
Um, I'm just a grumpy old
man. That's all it is.
I am a grumpy old man who wants
things to stay the same, you know?
Do I make any money off the NFL? I
don't. I do have the mute button.
You gotta you gotta love the mute button.
Anytime they cut to the chick on the
sideline. I just fucking, I hit mute,
you know, just trying to,
to keep it going, you know,
just for another couple more
weeks. How come we can't blah,
blah blah and the, okay. All right.
Jesus Christ. I think it really comes up.
I don't know. What are you gonna do?
It's a, you know, it's fucking over.
It's our own God damn faults. We just
had too much fucking fun without,
so, you know, the next thing
we start, just, you come home,
you get you, you tone it
down. Fucking tone it down.
Um, anyways, let's plow ahead
here. So I still haven't even said,
what is it, the, uh, super bowl. Who
Do you like? Panthers of Broncos.
You know, I was impressed
at the panthers. Fucking,
we're kicking the shit out of Arizona
and they didn't take their foot off the
gas pedal this week. Um, I don't know,
but the Broncos have that fucking defense,
but our offensive line steaks
doesn't stink. We're just banged up.
So I don't know. I don't
know how good the, uh,
okay.
I Dunno. I don't know if you know
what? I don't even fucking know.
I'm still so fucking annoyed
by that. Goddamn the finality.
I'm not even that we lost because I
felt Denver was the better fucking team.
God Damn mother fucker. All right.
That's it. Plowing ahead. Oh,
by the way, did I mention I saw a, the
hateful eight? Did anybody see that?
Did anybody see that? Hey, full
aid, I came up, I talked about it.
I saw it in 70 millimeter
at the arclight here in, uh,
in Los Angeles. Um,
it had an intermission and it
had an overture in the beginning.
There were no coming attractions
cause who the fuck's gonna shoot that?
The 70 millimeter. Right.
And I absolutely fucking love
that movie from start to finish.
I love the of it. I love
the whole, I just loved,
I loved it. I just the whole fuck.
It was just an experience like Terentino's
like I don't give a fuck about your
cell phone. How you yeah,
your fucking brain is all scrambled now
cause you're looking at an iPad screen.
All God Damn Day Long.
I don't give a fuck the movies this long.
This is the movie I wanted to make and
you can settle the fucking or leave.
Is it just an experience? I absolutely
fucking love that movie. Um,
I was speaking and was speaking of iPads,
so you see when the
Patriots iPads went out,
no stranger to the Broncos go out in
that weird as just one of those strange
things. Just one of those fluke
things that happen to happen and I,
it's all good.
It's all good because it happened to the
Patriots now had it happened the other
way around and it was in
our stadium. Oh Jesus.
How many months would ESPN talk
about that? You know, verse,
he called me today instead
of former quarterback, I
think it was for the giants.
I don't even know. It
was saying like, yeah,
we just take air out of the
ball all the fucking time.
Everybody did it and everybody does it.
Okay.
Once again, and I know you
guys are like, oh Jesus, Bill,
how long are you going
to harp on this? Well,
they talked about it for fucking
eight months. You know, I think since,
you know, the judge threw it out of court.
I mean it hasn't been eight
months since then. Has It?
September, October,
November, December, January.
You got another three
months of this shit. Um,
anyways, enough of that shit. I uh, oh
by the way, I started that, that um,
that series top boy,
top boy on a Netflix and
a fucking great show.
Two episodes in enjoying
it, but Jesus Christ,
you got to put on the fucking subtitles.
Good Lord mumble and fast as fuck.
It's almost as bad as peaky
blinders, but peaky blinders.
You can understand this shit was supposed
to happen like a hundred years ago.
This shit here as far as I can tell
supposed to be going on right now and I
still can't understand them. I don't
think they say in it enough. Um,
stamps.com everybody here, we got
a little advertising for this week.
stamps.com you know, there's gotta be
a better way to mail and ship stuff.
Go to the post office.
Takes up so much time. Uh,
leasing a postage meter is
way too expensive. Turns
out there is a better way.
stamps.com stamps.com you can buy
and print official US postage for any
[inaudible]
or package right from your
desk using your own cupboard.
Cuba even
gets special postage
discount. She can't find it.
The post office plus stamps.com is
more powerful than a postage at just a
fraction of the cost.
You can save at least 50% compared
to a postage meter annual.
Avoid all the time consuming
trips to the post office.
I use stamps.com any time I
send my posters out right now,
you can sign up for stamps.com
and use my last name,
burr for this special offer. Four
week trial plus $110 bonus offer,
including postage and a digital
stale and scale. Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you
do anything else, click on the
microphone@theofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com
enter
[inaudible].
All right.
[inaudible] m t watches movement watches
was started by two college dropouts.
Man, with the idea to make quality
watches that don't break your back.
Starting at just 95 bucks and sold online,
they cut out all the
bullshit retail markup. Um,
they sent me some watches.
He sings a fucking Ri.
Quality materials and sleek designs.
They're the perfect everyday watch. It's,
you know, if you get mugged, you
don't give a fuck right? Here you go.
Take the goddamn thing. I'll buy another
one before you get it home. Uh, easy.
It's easy. Order online
today for free shipping.
Free returns in a 24 month warranty.
Join the movement and say no to big brand
retail markups and saying yes to great
style. Check out MVMT
watches.com/burr and you'll get 15%
off your entire purchase. That's MVMT
watches.com/bar and lastly, but
not leastly blue apron, everybody.
All right. Listen, you don't
need to know how to cook,
but you need denied a cooker rate if you
want to start nailing the top fucking
chicks out there, right?
I'm kidding. All right. Now
it helps. Anything else,
especially when you look like me,
you know it's helpful. You
can whip up a dish, you know,
grab a couple of wine glasses, act like
you know what you're doing, you know,
but you'll go, I don't want to go
to the fucking supermarket. Well,
that's what blue apron
comes in. All right?
Not only do you get to feel like you
know your way around the kitchen,
but cooking your home means eating
healthier and saving money instead of
ordering expensive takeout
again. But where do you start?
Blue Apron has you covered
for less than $10 per meal.
Blue Apron delivers all the fresh
ingredients you need to create home cooked
meals. Just follow the easy
step by step instructions.
Each meal can be prepared
in 40 minutes or less.
No overwhelming trips to the grocery
store. No more said take out,
no matter your dietary preferences.
Blue Apron makes it a breeze to discover
and prepare dishes like chicken and
sage biscuit, pot pie,
shrimp and Pineapple
Fried race, Philly style,
Hoagie with green peppers, onions,
mushrooms and aged cheddar sauce,
chicken, scab, Fellini, whatever the
fuck this is with thrive. We get it.
Lemon butter, shrimp. What am I going
to read? The whole menu. All right,
I got it. There's a bunch of shit on it.
Tomato quiche with a simple green salad,
right in your own kitchen.
Not In the bathroom.
They make it in the kitchen and recipes
between 500 700 calories. Proportion,
delicious and good for you right now.
You can get your first two
meals for free@blueapron.com
slash [inaudible] that's
blue apron.com/per blue
apron. A better way to cook.
Um, all right, here we go.
You know, be cool though.
If there was like a female like
Vince Lombardi who came in,
you know what I mean? And she had
the exact same like, like demeanor,
nobody
tackling out there. What
the hell is going on
today will be the greatest day.
Yeah, they'll start it.
They'll have the classic sakes.
Okay.
All right. Everybody, grab
a towel. Cover your decks.
Let's focus on next week.
Um, oh, by the way, uh,
I want to thank, uh,
Brian Tishi for letting me be a part of
the Bonzo bash this past Friday night.
Uh, I got to go down there and
cohost it with him and, uh,
just the amount of drummers that I saw
that night and I got to stand behind him.
There's any youtube video you're going
to see my dumb fucking head just staring
at their bass drum foot. Um,
these are some of the guys that played
last Friday night. Stephen Perkins,
Jane's Addiction, Chad Smith
from the Chili peppers.
Dave Lombardo from dead
cross and a slayer.
Um, who else? I'm gone from memory.
Um, oh, there's a guy that, uh,
Greg Potter from the buddy rich band guy
plays in a buddy rich band and crushed
a Zepplin song that's pretty much
running the gamut, Simon, right?
Last time I saw Simon, right,
play a, sell him on the who made,
who tour a robber? Few. So from
skid row, last time I saw him,
they opened for Aerosmith, new years
eve, 1989, December 31st at the Boston.
It, um, will Calhoun was there,
Brad Whitford from Arrowsmith
Carmen, uh, apathy.
Oh my God, know Ray Luzia from corn
absolutely destroyed Achilles last fan.
Scott, John Hommel. I never heard
of fucking destroyed cashmere,
just so many fucking amazing drummers
and I actually got to sit in,
which is fucking hilarious. I got to sit
in, in between guys at that level. Uh,
I played that song off of, uh, the
presence album for your love and uh,
I'm sorry for your love
for your life and uh,
I wanna thank uh,
everyone in the Moby Dick's for
helping walk me through that song. Um,
I, you know, you know what it was,
I fucked up a lot during the song,
but I nailed the arrangement
as far as like all the changes.
I was on it for that. And
I find that if you do that,
that people in the crowd don't
notice that you fucking up the fills.
There was like one big Phil and I
fucking ribbed out on the thing.
I was so fucking pissed. Um, what
are you gonna do? But it was, uh,
it was just a fucking
amazing night and, uh,
four hours fucking long watching
these guys. And they had this
bottom fucking vista light set, the
exact same style kit that he had.
Um, a if you watched the song and
the song remains the same and this,
the fucking kick drum was wide
open. They had nothing in there.
They didn't even a filled
strip going across it.
It was one of the sickest sounds I've
ever heard in my life. Big 26 inch kit.
They had the two tympanies to the left
of the high hat and then the fucking
Gong. And it's, I'm so pissed
at the end of the song,
I didn't hit the fucking Gog.
How many fucking opportunities do you
get to do that? And I blew it. But, um,
I just had, I just had the
best time doing it. And uh,
then of course I'm driving home. It was
down in Anaheim and I'm driving home.
And the best thing about
driving home at night in La is,
is finally no traffic and
I'm fucking cruising. And uh,
all of a sudden the fucking five just
comes to a grinding halt in three,
four lanes,
merge down to one and then are
forced off of the highway into like a
neighborhood. Uh,
because the only time they obviously that
they can fix the highways is at night.
So I have empathy for these
state workers out here,
but um, suck for me
and I just, I complete,
I had like a fucking meltdown for about
five minutes and I was texting everyone
that I got a number from
that was on the show,
telling them not to
get on the five and uh,
fuck a Bruton. And once again,
I just don't understand why
people buy fast cars out here.
Unless you have a pickup truck with a
trailer and you could drive that car,
you can tow the car to a race track.
I just don't understand. You know,
these fucking cars you see out here,
they can go like 180 hundred
60 toward a miles an hour.
Some of these fucking cars. It's
like, where are you doing that?
I don't know.
It's fucking ridiculous. I beeped at
this lady today. I was probably a dick.
I just really,
I can't fucking stand people when
they sit at a God damn red light,
you're right behind them. And
then when the light turns green,
they put on their fucking left
turn signal and then you beat bad.
And they're like, what the fuck?
It's like you give me a heads up,
give me a heads up so I could have backed
off and gone around you your fucking
Dick. Now that 20 people
behind me are going to go by.
I'm going to miss the fucking
light. Now I'm on your schedule.
Yeah.
You know like that. That's
never happened to you.
You'd never been the person behind that
person. You don't fucking remember.
Now you're first in line.
You just say fuck it.
Yeah,
sorry. Most of this shit, everything
that I'm saying, women in the NFL,
all of this shit, most of this
shit has nothing to do with the,
it has to do with the fact
that my team lost, you know?
So now I'm just fucking
grumpy. Um, anyways.
Naela be the best day alive.
Okay.
It's weird. One for the
gipper. Um, alright. Oh, hey,
I'm going to be playing out live again.
If you guys, uh, Andy would stand up.
Oh, Dean del Ray. Dean del
raised a 50th birthday.
You got to come down to this at the
El Rey theater, del Ray at the El Rey.
Uh, it's going to be an
unbelievable fucking lineup of, uh,
comedians and musicians to
celebrate Dean Del Rey's 50th.
And of course, my fucking
Internet cuts out.
I finally had the fucking thing finally
had it. I had it all fucking lined up.
I was ready to read off the
whole thing. And what happens?
It just fucking disappears.
You fucking cunt. All right,
well, this is what I know.
Um,
Joe Rogan's going to be doing some standup
there. Uh, I will be on it. Christa,
Leah, let me get to the flyer
here. Let me get to the fly.
Uh, there it is. There's
the flyer. All right.
Brian red band, Joe Barton. Barnick
Rosebell tailgate legend Joe Barnick.
Dean del Rey's going to be there. And, uh,
after we do a bunch of stand up,
uh, we're going to do some, uh,
from what I heard,
there's going to be all these musicians
there and they're going to play the
entire highway to hell album. Uh,
Rudy SARS is going to be
there from a Ozzy Osborne,
uh, Dave Cushner from velvet revolver, ed,
the Gao does the music for F
is for family. Dave Lombardo,
Tracy guns, Gilby clack from guns and
roses. It's going to be fucking say,
it's going to be a blitz
going to be a lot of fun. Um,
so come on down February 2nd.
You can get tickets at, uh,
golden voice.com.
Um,
all right, let's, uh, let's
continue on here with, with the, uh,
with the podcast. What else did I
want to talk about? Is there anything,
anything at all? Is I, if
I, as I settle into the fact
that my fucking football
season is over, um, oh,
Jesus Christ to Patrice O'Neal benefit,
how the fuck did I almost forget that?
Uh, late gray Patrice O'Neil, the, I
think this is the fourth one we've done.
Um,
yeah, 13, 14, 15, 16. Yeah, this is
the fourth one's already flying by.
Um, it's sold out. There will be
a few tickets released at the, um,
right before the show starts.
It's always a few people that request
the tickets and then they don't show up.
So there's a chance if you walk
up there might be a sub tickets.
It's going to be an amazing
lineup. And as always, uh,
other than the money that we use
to, uh, pay to rent out the theater,
all monies goes to a Patricia's loved
ones and it's really made an unbelievably
positive effect on their lives.
Um,
you know,
his mom has been able to get a condo and
his stepdaughters is going to private
school since the benefit. And um,
just the quality of their lives
basically stayed the same, you know,
Patrice was taking care of
them. So, um, it's really,
it's the greatest thing that I'm involved
in during the course of the year and
I'm so happy that you guys
step it up every year and, um,
buy tickets.
I want to thank everybody who bought
that means the world to me and everybody
involved and all the comics that take
time out of their schedule to come down
there and um, and
perform. And it's just a,
it's just an awesome thing and we're just
going to keep doing it as long as you
guys keep showing up. All right.
So thank you. Thank you for that.
And with that, let's get into some
of the reeds here for their, uh,
for this week. All right. What are we
up to here? 33 minutes. Sorry. Alright.
Alright. Hacky hate. Hey
Bill, how I, yeah, he says,
I am not a patriots fan. I am a die
hard bears fan. After the Patriots lost,
all I saw on Facebook was people
trashing Brady and bringing up Trump and
deflate gate. I get it. They're on most,
they're on top most of the time and
people love to trash him or whoever's
winning at life.
Now let's stop giving excuses to these
pansy ass fucking sports fan who spent
sports fans who spend 90% of their
fucking time talking about gossip.
It all gets classified under
gossip. Every hack who was,
who was a static that the
pastry is lost is an asshole.
Especially the ones who will declare
they could care less about sports.
Congrats. You're about as cool
as the guy who paints his face.
The only time I talk shit about the
Patriots is to remind them of 1985 even.
That's pretty weak. Go bears.
Um, yeah, but you know,
if you're on top you got to expect that
people are going to give you shit. Um,
the only thing I didn't like was, was
when the, the uh, Broncos' defense,
you know, oh, we're getting sugar
here. What about Tom Brady? It's like,
well then when a fucking Superbowl win
four of 'em and they'll talk about you.
The Patriots never talked
shit about the Broncos.
They never said that they were better
than the Broncos. And I also love to,
it's just like, you know, they
were favorites. They were fit.
Like the Patriots made themselves
favorites that, you know,
what's really overrated is,
is being a favorite or being an underdog
has nothing to do with your team.
It has to do with the fucking dope in
the buffalo wild wings who's betting on
games? All right.
What Vegas tries to do is they try to
get money on both sides of the ball,
so they try to pick a number. All right,
that's going to entice people to go 50 50.
That's why the line changes
during the course of the week.
Did one team get better or another
team get get worse? I mean,
if there's an injury, yes, but
generally speaking, no, what happens is,
is this too much money going to one side?
So they need to entice people to
come back the other side. Because if,
if you know that you can't have like 90%
of the money on one side of the ball,
that could completely fuck
over the gambling ring or the,
uh, they don't like those
odds. And because Ty's lose,
that's enough to tip it in their fucking
favor. That's basically what goes on,
which is why, you know,
if you look back in oh seven when the
Patriots beat the giants the last game of
the year,
and the giants put up like fucking 33 or
34 points and we only won by like three
or something.
That's why like a month later we
were still 14 point favorites.
It had no, the Patriots are
overhyped. They weren't overhyped.
What happened was the Superbowl brings
out people who don't know shit about
football. All right? It
brings out the fucking ladies.
It brings out all you know this, this
is not the worst in a super bowl party.
If you give a shit about football,
if you really liked the super bowl,
if really like football, if
you're really a football fan,
you watch it alone or you watch it with
like two or three other people that keep
their fucking mouth shut, right? Um,
but what happens is during the Superbowl
that brings out all the fucking,
the novice fans that people don't even
watch and all they see is 18 and old
fucking bearer. They know
Brady. Like they know,
they know Tom Brady the way I
know Darth Vader. All right.
I can't tell you a fucking
thing about the last, like,
I don't even know how many there's
been since the original three.
I know Veda is fucking Luke's
father and that fucking,
uh,
Luke in layer a brother and sister and
that they kind of had like this sexual
tension in one to fuck each
other in the beginning,
which I think is a really weird thing
to put into a kid's movie, don't you?
Um,
okay.
Maybe he didn't know that
when he initially wrote it
and then he just needed a
good left turn when he was writing the
second one. I have no fucking idea,
but I think the way he tried to make it
up was with those durables in the third
one, you know, going where
the fuck they did, you know,
I know what the fuck they did. So
anyway, so that's as much as I can.
As much as I know about star wars,
these people know about football.
So then they come in,
they go to Vegas and everybody goes in
and thinks that they're fucking Sean
Connery and James Bond,
right. They way, you know,
they fucking go down there and
they got some Almond Vegas suit on.
Their wife's wearing
some fucking, you know,
sparkly number and everybody's
out there, you know,
stepping outside of themselves
and say, I want to gamble.
I want to get in the action.
Who's playing? I don't know
who that other team is.
I know Tom Brady is, let me, yeah,
let me put a hundred bucks on his
done the Clef of his fucking chin.
And that's how the line goes from
what it should be about three,
four points to all the way up to 14.
That's what the fuck happens. All right.
And that was for everybody who doesn't
fucking gamble. Okay. All right,
cool enough already. We get it.
Your team lost and you fucking,
you were in a country mood. Um, thank
God that guy fell out of the stance.
He didn't even look that drunk. I
just loved his fucking gap jeans.
Just fucking straight up in the air.
All right. Next question here. Um, oh,
by the way, if you'd like to
donate to this podcast, um,
all you gotta do is just go to,
uh, next time you go to Amazon.
If the next time I'm going
to buy something on that,
uh, just go to my website,
Bill bird.com. Click on the podcast page,
and then you just click on the Amazon.
It just takes you there. It doesn't
cost you any extra money. Uh, you might,
you know, later on in life, if
your index finger wears out,
you might think like, you know what,
if I didn't do those extra two
clicks with my index finger,
maybe I would've had another 10 minutes
of joy and no fucking constant pain and
my index finger. Other than that,
there's really nothing I even do it.
I even go when I go to Amazon. Well,
why wouldn't I guess I get the money,
right? You know, I did. I went on
there and I fixed my fucking car.
I Dunno what the fuck capita, my
cooler this year, that the rose bowl,
it's been to every rose bowl that I've
been to and I've been to eight of them at
this point and I never had
a fucking problem. And at
some point, like my cooler,
basically it opens up
to a point, you know,
the hinges stop it from opening and
then there's this strap to keep it from
going any further. And I
don't know what happened. Um,
cause I fucking passed out like at
like 10 o'clock in the morning. So,
and I didn't even notice
that my cooler was fucked up.
But at the end of the night when
I got my cooler back, the, uh,
it had basically been decapitated.
The strap was busted and the hinges were
busted. And I was like, what the fuck?
What happened? Yeah, it's like the
hulk opened the thing up or something.
She's like, just open it a little, it's
fine. But then I was thinking of Warren,
I fell down was I was drunk that I
land on the cooler and it's like, no,
I w I wouldn't notice that
I landed flat on my butt.
I landed like that fucking guy.
What? He fell out of the stands.
It's how I fell. I fell on the grass.
Do you realize I was on a fairway,
a straight fairway golf course and
I lost my balance and fell down.
That's how fucking drunk I wasn't, you
know what? It was fucking great. Um,
so anyways, I went to a, Oh,
actually I didn't go to Amazon,
they just looked up Igloo m cooler
repair kit and they got like,
there's two different kinds of hinges and
I accidentally ordered two of them and
I only need one of them.
So I have an extra repair kit and I
know you know the odds and they send you
like three sets of hinges. You
know, if you have like the,
the giant one,
you're the person who kills his wife and
doesn't want anybody to know and just
say she's on vacation and he cuts her up.
Like they have that size hinge for that
cooler and then they just got, you know,
the happy drunk that falls down
on New Year's Day, you know,
so they come with three
sets of hinges for each.
So I have an entire extra one. So
anybody out there who has like a,
a cooler that needs to be
replaced, it comes with everything.
Even like the drain little drain hole,
fucking spout thing, it's got that, um,
the strap does come separately.
I don't have an extra strap,
but I have an extra a repair
kit. So if anybody wants it,
send us an email with an address and
I'll send it out to you because what else
am I going to do with it? I'm
not going to throw it out.
And someday if I ever move, um, you know,
I've got to pack up something that I
don't even fucking need. So there you go.
Oh, by the way, uh,
I'm still in the running here
to maybe get this drum room
made slash podcast room in the back of
my garage, um, as always, this major,
major fucking structural issues. But, um,
I don't know. It's just gotta. I gotta
I gotta show up that part of the house,
but there's this, all these,
these all these fucking issues that I
can't even talk about because, you know,
I'm getting a permit. I'm doing all of
that fucking shit. I know. Somebody like,
well, you don't need
a full computer muted,
full if you're building
within the structure,
if you know the Antigone square footage
of Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I know all that shit. But
like, I just, you know,
anytime you start hammering
in your fucking garage,
you neighbors here at
the fucking rat you out.
I just don't need the fucking headaches.
So I'm doing my due diligence
and it's taking a long time.
But, um, I'm gonna, I'm gonna make this,
I'm gonna make this fucking happen
and I have a 71 Ludwig green sparkle,
all bottom sized drums and I'm gonna
make sure that they fucking fit in there
and I'm going to fucking, I don't
give a shit. What do I care? Right.
You know,
the oceans are all fished out. The
government takes all your fucking money.
You know, I don't give a fuck. I'm going
all out with this thing, this thing.
I'm literally going to be able to
pull. I'm going to tell this guy,
if I'm able to do this and I'm not going
to have a fucking problem legally and I
could build the fucking
thing I want to build,
I'm literally going to be able to play
at two o'clock in the fucking morning and
no one's even going to
hear it. They might,
it might sound like a
stereos on really low,
but I'd never be a Douche enough
to play then, um, at least sober.
That'll be great then. Right?
Anytime I'm bugging my wife,
I can just walk out the back
door, go into my garage,
sit down and put on a Zeplin
album, guns and roses.
Fucking uh, all my fucking Shit I
listened to when I was growing up.
Queens of the Stone Age, you know? Right.
What w what else do you fucking
need? Uh, you know what else I need?
I need a bar out there, right?
Flat screen TV. You know,
it's funny about a man cave when somebody
really goes throws down and their
fucking man cave. All I hear
is I am not happily married.
And what you're doing is you're building
a mini version of what your life would
look like if you weren't what your house
would look like if you weren't married.
Like after you show them the house
with all the throw pillows and all the
fucking popery and all that shit.
You bring your buddy out to the
garage and your psych. Yeah.
If I wasn't married, like this
is what it would look like.
But you know what's funny about that?
I'm old enough to know that if
your house did look like that,
the ice, I see the loneliness in it.
Cause the bottom line is a
man cave. What it is is like
what's your building is
what you wish you had,
you wish you could afford when
you were fucking 22 years old.
That's basically it. And the problem
is, is if you do it honestly,
if you're actually work
your balls off, you know,
and you don't steal from anybody
or any of that fucking shit,
it's going to take it
to your about 50 LSU,
one of these fucking nerds and silicone
valley that comes up with an app or some
shit. You know, you really don't
get paid until you get close to 50.
That's just how it is, you
know? It's just how it is.
Except for Cam Newton. He's
getting paid around. Yeah.
Do I write down? Don't worry. He's
having more fun than that guy.
If you look up fun in the dictionary. Um,
anyways, I, um, yeah,
I'm going to fucking make a
little podcasting. I mean,
I don't have a lot of
room, but, uh, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna fucking do it up.
Right. And, uh, you know,
getting back and taking lessons again
through the shit that I'm actually paying
attention to now that I never paid
attention to how I hold onto this sticks
where I'm hitting the
snare drum, my balance,
all of that shit used to be
all about going on youtube,
seeing some guy do one of those Gospel
Chop fucking licks in an I'm going to go
down here and fucking just do this for
fucking nine days in a row and then I'll
be able to do that, you know, pull this,
fill off next time I walk into Guitar
Center. And, uh, and then meanwhile,
all my other planks shocked.
And, uh, I've just had this
total epiphany about all
of it. And a, it's funny,
I'm not doing nearly as
much as I used to do,
but I think I'm playing better than
I ever played. And uh, yeah, I dunno.
It's fucking exciting. It gives me a
reason to get up in the morning, you know?
So anyways, let's move on
to the next question here.
Uh, oh my God.
Did I tell you guys how I butchered that
fucking pork chop meal that I made? Oh,
I'm still sick over that.
Okay.
Ugh. I'm like,
I'm eating pork chops again this week
cause I have to redeem myself. All right,
so the hacky hate. Yeah. Yeah.
That just kind of comes with winning
games and whatever. I'm all right.
No Asian diversity at the
Oscars. Bill hello from Canada.
Would love to hear what your take is on
why no one is complaining about the lack
of agents at the Oscars.
Oh, you motherfucker. That's
the bit I was going to do.
That was the bit I was going to do.
Yeah, that's, it's as egos as an agent.
I don't care because a,
I suspect we aren't producing good
enough shit not to not, oh wait,
we're not producing good enough
shit. Not because we're Asian. B,
Asians aren't getting sweet
rolls because I'm not profitable.
They aren't going to cast an Asian
parentheses or black or female actor that
would make more money out
of some white conspiracy.
Dude, you had like fucking two
sets of parentheses in there.
Asians aren't getting sweet rolls
because it's not profitable.
They aren't going there. They
aren't going to not cast an Asian
are black or female actor that, oh, I
see what you're saying. They're not,
they aren't going to not cast an Asian
actor that would make more money out of
some white conspiracy. So you're saying
if they, if they would make them money,
then they would see,
who cares if you don't like
how the Oscars define the best,
whatever. I don't get why.
And then that's the end of it. I
see what you're saying. Well, yeah,
you're looking at it from a very, uh,
like money. Like I think that's a
lot of times sometimes, you know,
it looks like it's racism. A
lot of times it's just money.
But what I think American cinema is
finally realizing is that there's a whole
bunch of other people in the world that
they can actually get money from if they
gave a fuck to make a movie
that would appeal to them.
And the only thing,
reason why I think they're doing that
is because everybody's stole movies and
it's so hard to make
money off of them now.
And there's such a big
fucking risk because what
happened to the music business
has happened slash is happening
to the movie business right now,
which is why there's really no more
like from like $20 million to like $70
million. They don't make movies in
that budget anymore. They just don't.
It's either like some fucking $100 million
star wars action hero movie or it's
like fucking below $10 million it seems.
I'm all the way down to like a hundred
grand, like in the sort of, you know,
micro budget fucking thing. Um,
so yeah, I see what you're
saying. Yeah. I mean the, yeah,
there's no agent's area there. Where's
the outcry for that? Well, people don't,
people give a fuck about themselves.
That's the one thing that I can
say about people in general,
straight across the board, you know,
which is why I guess white people need,
because they're running shit, quote,
run and shit. You know what I mean?
Like they're all cooperating with one
another because there's white people in
those positions.
They need to take the time to actually
give a fuck about other stuff.
Cause I gotta be honest with you.
I've thought that kid that played
easy in a straight Outta Compton,
he should've gotten nominated. He was,
he was the fucking Shit and that movie,
I should know that actors name he
was, you know what, God dammit.
Why don't I step outside my whiteness.
I'm going to,
I'm going to set the example here
right now and I'll tell you right now,
there's nobody having more fun right
now going on the Internet than this guy.
You look up fun on the Internet. There'll
be a picture of me easy. He actor,
um, I'm
Eric Lynn ride is here.
Jason Mitchell on playing easy
e that fucking guy was the,
he should have got something
even get a golden globe.
You get nominated for that. Um,
that was one of those movies that
I actually didn't even want to see.
There was some line that
what's his face? Uh, um,
Giamatti said, you know what I mean? You
can't try it out like that, like that,
that phony yelled, whatever the fuck
he yells. I go, Jesus Christ, this,
this looks really heavy
handed. You know what I mean?
And then they always have
to have the uh, you know,
they always have to have the white white
angel and those movies when they show
racism, so then white people will go so
they can lie to themselves and be like,
yeah, if I was there, that's
the white guy. I would be,
I'd be the Angel White Guy. I wouldn't
be the, the A, you know, the racist guy.
Um, yeah, no, it's a very,
it's a very interesting,
the whole fucking thing is
really interesting. I don't know.
I have no idea. I mean I think
you shouldn't just say, look,
black actors should be nominated.
You should fucking then back it up.
You know what I mean? And give shout
outs to people that fucking deserve.
He's to be like Jason Mitchell, plain
easy and straight outta Compton.
I would a fuck is going to say
he should have got something. Um,
or maybe they did do that. I've
got to be honest with you. I don't,
I don't really pay attention to award
shows. I fucking can't stand up. Um,
they're horrific. They're fucking
horrific. They're boring as hell.
There's usually one moment
that's worth fucking watching.
And at that with the Internet,
you're not going to miss it.
They're just going to show it to you.
So why would you waste four hours
of your life watching the shit?
Like for the Golden Globes, the, the,
the moment of the night was Jim Carrey.
Jim Carrey stole that. Even that
fucking speech was hilarious.
And from what I've heard,
um, from people out here,
he just winged that thing. That's
how fucking funny that guy is. Um,
and watching him do that and the brutal
honesty of it really made me wish I
could still watch him to stand up,
to be honest with you. Um, all right,
here we go to your
health. Good Syrup Bill.
I've heard you discussed many topics with,
with yourself on the podcast
about health and longevity, uh,
of the major topics I.
E. Food and exercise.
I would have to suggest considering
another area to focus on breathing.
Yeah. Jesus. I got to work on
this too. Breathing is huge.
How you breathe in the types of breaths
you take during the day to really change
your body for the better. I just
literally thought about breathing.
I got more relaxed.
This is this yoga shit that I
try to slow my brain down for.
Conscious breathing,
conscious breathing. Oh,
you're going to plug your book in
the middle of this. You motherfucker.
You know what? You got
me. He suckered me in,
but I'm going to read it like deep
thoughts by Jack Handy. Here we go.
Conscious breathing is a book
in a great place to start.
Also,
a man by the name of Wim Hoff is doing
amazing things and has been on Joe
Rogan's podcast. You may not
have three hours to listen to it,
but if you run into Joe, I'm sure
he can give you the breakdown.
Thanks for the free laps.
Um,
no. I listen to anybody that's on
Rogan's podcast. Joe Rogan's podcast,
the fastest fucking three hours you're
ever going to spend. You've ever,
ever lucky enough to be a fucking
guest. You can be like admin.
You're like 40 minutes and then all of a
sudden you like it. How the fuck is it?
Like seven o'clock at night? That
guy, I missed her. I miss my meal. Um,
well I'll, I'll give it a chance.
I'll give it a try. I know I,
I definitely need to
fucking stress less and a,
that's always like one of my goals. I
haven't been drinking this year though.
The day after the Rose Bowl
was the last time I boozed
um,
I had one gulf of wine after I made this
really rich dinner and in my stomach I
needed to settle it. So my
wife was drinking some wine.
I just took a gulp of that. And
then the last three nights in a row,
I'm getting rid of these Rosebowl
beers. I just drink like one light beer.
I just have one and then, then I'm done.
And it just kind of makes me sleepy.
But I'm just trying to free
up some room in the fridge.
Cause every year at the
end of the Rose Bowl,
I get stuck with all the extra beers
and like fucking 15 cans of half used
mustard. Um,
I get all the condiments and a broken
cooler. All right? Trash in the ocean.
Hey, bill, I know you talk about
this all the time on your podcast,
but believe it or not, there are
people who do not believe our trash
being dumped to the ocean is a problem.
While there's always
going to be those people,
there's also people that thought
the fucking world was flat. Well,
I guess I would have
thought the world is flat.
If I live back then people didn't think
that we were f we are owning an effect
on the climate. You know,
all the fucking trees that we've cut
down that alone. You know what I mean?
It's, um, all right. Anyways,
he says there was another
scientific study done.
If you believe in that kind of thing,
that state's plastics will
outweigh fish in the ocean by 2050.
Yeah, I saw that.
I don't think that that's going to happen
because I have a feeling that mother
nature has had enough with
us and will, you know,
when they keep predicting by 2090,
the population will more than
fucking quintuple. I think that,
you know, we're already long past the
tipping point. Scientists have said,
we're past the point where we can
even fix this fucking thing. So I,
this is like when you can't do your
homework at some point you're like, mom,
and she comes down and helps you out. I
think Mother Nature is going to do that.
And uh, she's an old school mom and
she's going to slap the shit out of us.
Um,
but you don't need to
listen to me say this.
Just listen to George Karl and he'll
tell you all about it. I'm all right.
He said,
I guess these assholes assume there'll
be dead by then and don't give a shit.
Long time listening to hear, just
saw you in Indy back in October.
I can share you. We aren't all ignorant
KKK or gym or say fancy. And I,
you know, I just say that just
to fuck with you. Jesus Christ.
I grew up outside of Boston.
Half the people in the clan would go
there and be like, all right, hey,
take it easy. You know, I understand,
but easy. All right, thanks.
And Go fuck yourself. And
then they sent me the, uh,
the unbelievably depressing
link, which I don't,
I don't even go to them anymore.
I don't even go to many markers.
All they do is depress me. All right?
Average amount of waste produced
by humans, Jesus Christ,
which is staring into this. Hey Bill,
I'm from Columbia and love your
podcast and your stand up comedy. Hey,
that's fucking great.
Oh, you're from Columbia.
I thought you were down there listening.
I'm bored over. You're from there,
right? You'll live there at some point.
You still listen to the podcast is
still cool. Uh, he goes, I'm the are.
She goes, I don't know who
the fuck wrote is. He goes,
the other day I was wondering how much
poop is produced by humans on a daily
basis. And I did a little research on
the Internet and some calculations,
which I would like to share with
you and your audience. Okay?
According to the world fact book,
the world population consists
of 7 billion, 174,000, 611.
Wait a minute. Why don't let
7,174,611,584 people,
and the average human being
weighs around 62 kilograms. Oh,
you motherfucker. I want to know what
that is in pounds I wagon. I gotta.
I gotta switch that over. I want
to see where the fuck I'm at.
Okay.
Wait, what did you just say?
62 what do you guys think?
The average person who, I haven't say the
average person weighs about a hundred.
A lot of starving people.
I've got 162 pounds.
Okay.
What he's what he's
saying here. All right. 62
and
oh, B s. All right.
Okay.
That's equal to 136 pounds. Holy Shit.
God Damn it. There's a lot of small
or starving people in the world.
Okay.
All right. Now, the average,
that means I am right now,
I'm like 40 pounds over the average
and the average human being. All right.
Now the daily average for stool crows is
one ounce per 12 pounds of body weight,
which means the average
person pope's 11.39 ounces.
Therefore, each day the planet receives
2,295,876 metric tons of shit,
but since the average stool is
75% water too, this is gross,
it will be safe to say that humans produce
1,721,000 hundred seven metric tons
of poop every day. Jesus Christ,
you really taken all the fun out of
this podcast to put this in perspective.
I think you put it into perspective,
but he's going to keep going at the
empire state building weighs 350,000 tons,
so human beings puked the equivalent of
five giant turds the size of the empire
state building. If we add
farts to the equation,
this fucking dude is all in
the average person farts
17 times a day. That's it.
Try eating a salad. Fucking
double your numbers.
You Break Dan Marino's
record times 17 times a day,
producing a litter, a liter
of Fart in total or litter.
L, I. T. T. E. R. That's
a litter of Fart in total,
which gives a new meaning
to a breathing fresh air.
I have included the links
where I got the information
at the end of this email.
And when you think about it on top
of eating our own rollerblades,
we're eating our own shit. By the way,
everything you read or hear
about Columbia is true.
That go have a meaningful experience
with yourself. Let me go. Oh,
that means go fuck yourself. Ah,
this guy's a clever son of a bitch.
Um, Jesus Christ. Well,
you know what? Hey,
how about I end the podcast with
what I promised to do last week,
which is I was gonna start reading
segments from the Bible. Now granted,
I don't own a Bible. All right,
let's start with John Three
16 because I'm a sports fan.
John Three
68 he sat it onto you with,
all right,
John Three 16 for God so loved the world
that he gave his only his one and only
son, that whoever believes
in him shall not perish,
perish, but have eternal life.
Well, that's straight forward.
He let his kid die. So as long as
you believe that that happened,
you will not die. You will have
eternal life. You will live forever.
Think about that forever.
You know you have has been at the DMV.
Just imagine that. Except it never ends,
right. What the fuck would you do forever?
There's no way that that's
fucking true. You know,
movies don't go on forever.
Planets don't go on forever or
livable. Planets don't go on forever.
I'll fuck. This is why I don't
read the Bible and I, sorry,
I don't fucking get all right,
let's, let's, let's, uh,
let's just look up Bible
passages. Bib. Ellie,
it'd be funny if this actually
got me back to going to church.
I still loved going to church. You
know what I mean? I still like going,
you know, Gabe and my dad, JJ has cries.
There's die for Ross and his [inaudible].
Mm.
From the dead. Alright.
Encouraging Bible Verses Hope
Bible Verses Bible verses,
but friendships, Bible
verses. Let's give hope.
Encouraging. Well, when a fuck is it? Ah,
I just wanted to open it like
the phone book, the Bible.
I'm gonna look up the Bible.
Please read the Bible,
www free bible on your
phone. I don't want it.
I want it on my fucking screen. I
want amber. No. What? Cheeseburger.
Visual Kim James Bible.
Commit thy way unto the Lord.
Trust also in him and he shall
bring it to pass. Bring one
commit day way unto the Lord. All right,
so walk in the general direction
of the Lord. Trust also in him,
while if I'm walking towards a marinade,
isn't that trusting him? Winning.
I'm creeping up on him anyway, man.
Just making sure everything's cool
and walking your way. But you know,
just wave your white flag.
Okay.
Don't open a trap door
when I get there dude.
And he shall bring it to pass.
Okay,
Genesis. Oh, I remember reading this.
It like makes sense for like
three fucking sentences.
And then you just like
what? In the beginning,
God created the heaven and the earth
and the earth was without form and void
and darkness was upon the face of the
deep period.
The deep what and the spirit of God
moved upon. That's like when they go,
you know, they got to eat up some clock.
Darkness was upon the face of the deep
and the spirit of God moved upon the face
of the waters. I thought there wasn't any
that there wasn't any
water, wasn't anything.
How was the water for his
face to be on? And God said,
let there be light and there
was light. Let that be.
There was sound. Is this
Bon Scott? God said,
let there be light and there was light.
Well what was he doing before that?
He was just sitting in the
darkness all by himself.
Just one day he's laying there
going, I'm going to make some shit.
And God saw the light
that it was good and God divided
the light from the darkness.
God called the light days like Cam
Newton. Everything's about the same guy.
I'll tell you right now, nobody's
having more fun than God making Earth.
He's like a kid in the candy store that
doesn't exist and kids don't exist cause
he hadn't made it yet.
Oh fuck this genesis.
Okay,
let's look up job. Let's
see what old job had to say.
Where the fuck is he? Well, let's read
Titus. That's the name of a comic I know.
How about that? Alright, Paul,
a servant of God and an
apostle of Jesus Christ
according to the faith of God's elect
and the acknowledging of the truth,
which is after godliness.
I feel like somebody is
trying to sell me a car. Oh,
that was all one sentence
in hope of eternal life,
which God that cannot lie
promised before the world began.
Dude, this is like the the like
God called everything you know,
before you even born and all that.
But half in do times manifested
his word to you know,
and I thought this would be a funny
bit, this is just fucking annoying.
But half the do times manifested
his word through preaching,
which is committed unto me according
to the commandment of God, our savior.
It's just, it just goes in circles to
Titus, my own son. After the common faith,
he had another kid,
he had Jesus and he
had Titus grace, mercy,
and peace. Who are they as grace?
Grace did. Was she another virgin?
How many times is it going to use
this virgin? Think he banged them
right?
He had Jesus with Mary and then grace
was his fucking side piece and he had
Titus. All right.
Okay.
For this cause left ID and Crete that
thou should have set in order the things
that are wanting in orders. Elders
in every city as I appointed thee,
if any, be blameless. The husband of
one wife having faithful children,
not accused of riot or unruly.
It's not a sentence or maybe
it was back then. You know,
if I get judged someday, you know, and,
and God's standing there and being like,
I just spoke to it. I, you
know, I tried to get through.
I try to get through the book.
I don't know what to tell you
as far as I can see, it's
a bunch of fragments.
All right?
They're not complete thoughts. You know,
you can't write just because you put a
period at the end of it doesn't make it a
sentence.
Right?
That's a podcast for this week. Once
again, congratulations to the Broncos.
Congratulations to the lady who got
a job. I'm gonna end this positive.
Gradually says to the lady who got
the job there at the buffalo bills.
I'm sure you're going to do a great
job. I'm just a grumpy old fucking man.
His team lost. All right.
Congratulations to the panthers. Um,
I look forward to seeing
Cam Newton, you know,
play against Peyton manning.
It's going to be great.
I love that he called him the
sheriff. Um, I thought that was cool.
You know, the best of the old versus the
best of the new. So I'm an old fucker,
so I'm gonna have to root. I got a
group for P, uh, the Denver Broncos,
the AFC and Peyton
manning. Um, even though I,
the panthers and I love the way they
fucking play in their defenses to shit.
And um, I don't know. I just hope
it's a good game. I hope the panthers,
if they're gonna win or the Broncos,
I just don't want anybody beating
the fuck out of anybody. Right.
But I will tell you as always, I
will be watching it by myself. Okay.
I'm not going to, I might go to a
Superbowl party cause my team's out it,
but I don't think so.
I want to see Peyton's last game and
I hope it goes out like Elway and a,
I'm going to do what I always do. All
right, I'm going to tape the game.
You let it go for a good
90 minutes. As I mentioned,
you shut your phone off. You get the
grill going, you crack a couple of beers,
you know, you make
yourself a burger or two,
you invite a couple of
friends over and then he guy,
let's sit down and watch it. And you
blow through all the fucking beginning in
the hope of the
brave ride bump kickoff. And there we go.
Blow through all the fucking commercials.
Fast forward through Beyonce
lip sinking during halftime.
You get caught up halfway through
the third fucking quarter. And uh,
and if there were any cool commercials
that you missed, you have them recorded,
but someone's going to put
them up online anyways.
You're not going to miss a fucking thing.
And you can watch the Superbowl and about,
I dunno, you can watch it about two,
two hours and 20 minutes, two
hours, two and a half hours.
It's fucking tremendous. All
right. God bless you guys yet,
go fuck yourselves and I'll
check on Thursday. All right.